Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
So one of the downfalls of the election of
Donald Trump has been
a lot of grifters who have emerged in the
so called resistance, quote unquote resistance,
um, that have their, honestly have really
found a way to enrich themselves and to make
themselves famous in there.
Let's just say US sensible opposition to Donald
Trump.
I say that because I think they really appreciate
Donald Trump because he's made their careers.
But I digress.
One of those grifters is in trouble yet again.
Michael Abba Naughty has been charged, uh,
with conning stormy Daniels out of $300,000.
I want to read a couple of tweets that came
directly from the southern district of New
York Attorney General's office.
Uh, because ironically enough they took to
the same platform that Michael I haven't had
to used to make himself famous and they took
to Twitter to announce that he was now going
to be arrested and indicted.
Um, quote us attorney analysis indictment
of Michael Avanav, a per aggravated identity
theft engaging in a scheme to defraud a former
client, us a USA Berman Michael, a naughty,
uh, abused and violated the core duty of an
attorney, the duty to his client as alleged.
He used his position to steal a trust to still
an advance on the client's book deal as alleged.
He blatantly lied to and stole from his client
to maintain his extravagant lifestyle, including
to pay for, among other things, a monthly
car payment on a Ferrari far from zealously
express representing his client Ivan Naughty
as alleged.
His stead engage in outright deception and
theft victimizing rather than advocating for
his client.
It was always something about that guy's character
that really struck me is as a con man.
I mean, admittedly when he said he wanted
to run for president, I was like, oh, this
will be interesting.
Um, but you know, a hustler's a hustler.
I mean, there's really not much more to say
about that, but I think most people saw it.
And the problem is that sometimes hustlers
do a good thing.
I mean, uh, I have an adi did actually bring
forth evidence that led to the arrest of r
Kelly.
Um, so, you know, not all the time, I mean,
sometimes a hustle it can be useful, but usually
there's more bad that they do then good.
And as we've seen, this is not the first time
he's done something.
Um, extremely criminal.
Uh, there's an amazing piece in vanity Vanity
fair.com, uh, that really gives the background
and to the last trouble, the avid naughty
got into using his power and his influence,
his followers on Twitter.
I mean, Twitter followers is a really powerful
thing, especially when you're taking on the
president of the United States.
He has nearly a million followers on Twitter.
And he used pressure from his Twitter presence
and its ability to ability to wrangle media,
uh, to basically extort, um, Nike and to attempted
to extort them out of 22 point $5 million,
uh, for him to quote, give them full confidentiality
and ride off into the sunset.
Uh, and for that, um, you really have to read
this piece in Vanity Fair because they described,
you know, I didn't even realize it, but they
describe how as he was on his way to the meeting
with Nike, he tweeted out about the scandal,
uh, that was happening with allegedly happening
with Nike.
And as he went up the escalator to go to that
meeting and he's smiling at the number of
retweets and the likes that he got and, and
all the buzzing that's happening on his and
phone, you know, he's getting those endorphins
firing golfer.
You know what I mean?
Because it gets a good feeling to get 5,000
retweets.
It's the best feeling in the world for a social
path.
Like Michael, I have an Adi.
As he reached the top of the escalator, the
FBI was there, uh, to arrest them.
And, um, that was, that was that.
So we have a con man who affiliated himself
with the resistance, quote unquote resistance,
who made himself famous, um, as a result of
his opposition to Donald Trump.
And as it turns out, he is nothing more than
a too big condom man.
Just like Donald Trump.
Maybe that, why that's maybe that's why he
was so good at opposing Donald Trump.
Um, but to his, um, not to his credit, but
there was a quote he said that I think was
worthwhile and Vanity Fair.
He basically said that, you know, I was like,
Icarus, I flew too close to the sun.
It's a good quote.
Uh, but just still a con man, Mike.